e
e e
all right well let's get started I
believe First up is labor to talk about
the second injury fund is that
right
yeah so welcome commissioner Maryfield
and welcome representative
[Laughter]
Maguire all
right so I'm going to make sure the last
time I was here I did not uh identify
myself so uh for the record I'm Ken
marfield commissioner at the Department
of Labor I'm joined by Deputy
Commissioner Danielle Albert and uh uh
we observed your disc discussion
yesterday um so I think I know uh some
topics that you'd like to discuss yeah
the elevators and the yep several topics
actually yeah so I think we're starting
around page 61 is that
it
um the house buil too
oh do we have an extra copy of House
Bill 2 for represented
Maguire is there one
there yeah yeah that should be good okay
very good so page
61 um you want to do the elevators first
you like sure sure just start at the top
okay
um so we're wondering about the fee
should it be
higher yeah and and I can tell you um
from the history that I have been able
to look at it does not appear that the
fee has changed maybe ever um in in the
records that I have locally at the
department uh at least since fiscal
2014 uh it has been that $50 I can also
tell you that um in that category of
Revenue we collect just under $300,000
in a in a typical year um if you went to
a 100 you know it would result in
$300,000 or so how many people work
inspecting elevators we have uh uh the
elevators inspect inspectors we have
three and a half uh uh elevator
inspectors including the
chief um we don't do all of the elevator
inspections however we have we have a
piece of that but we do issue what we're
talking about here is the $50 annual fee
for each elevator and so there's no
other fees that go into this category
when I describe the $300,000 we're just
talking about the certificate that tells
the public this elevator has been in
inspected and we believe is safe I mean
is there a particular accounting unit
for those three and a half
people uh yes they're part of the
Inspection Division um so they reside
there in accounting unit
6100 okay what page is that in house
bill one do we
know I just want to generally speaking
it's a good idea to keep fees at least
as much as expenses right for that item
so okay so labor it's page 301 page 301
okay let's
it starts on 300 sorry 300 and
301 what that it starts on 300 300 okay
Inspection Division oh but there's 30
people there right okay so all of our
all of our wage and our inspectors our
safety inspectors the boiler inspector
all of those people and the support
staff that assist them are all in this
accounting unit okay so but roughly for
these 31 people they they are costing us
a little over 100,000 a piece if you
just take the bottom line and and
expenses here so um so we're a little
under if you have three and a half
people creating 300,000 you see what I
mean they should create 400,000 or
something Al that's not the only
category of Revenue that they generate
oh okay um those three and a half people
do I don't have it right I don't have
have it all broken out for you on the
spot here but um all all told the
Inspection Division far far out collects
their expenses to the degree that we
will turn over at the end of the fiscal
year over $2 million to you in general
funds so they they outproduce their
expenses by far by far oh so the they're
costing three million but they're
creating five or something like that is
that the fair enough uh uh you might
remember the last time we visited I
talked about the restricted fund and I
and uh representative you had a question
about the restricted fund yesterday um
that was a creation of the legislature
in
2011 and it represents all of the fees
fines uh licenses every other type of
Revenue that we generate at the labor
department goes into the restricted fund
there's a poor portion of our operations
including our salaries in fact the
portion of that is supported by the
restricted fund but the balance at the
end of the year is turned over to the
state in general funds there's a a
transfer at the end of the year and um I
mentioned last time we visited uh our
best four years of general fund
production have been the last four years
typically historically the department
produce between 1 and and a half million
and we've exceeded 2 million uh each of
the last four
years okay so what is the uh division
think maybe $75 does that sound
reasonable yes representative Rong um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
commissioner marold for taking my
question um I missed when you said the
last time the fee was um increased yeah
uh I have no knowledge of it at least
since I have been at the labor
department and and certainly since
fiscal
2014 uh the fee has been exactly the
same and and written in statute okay
speaking of which I would like to
rewrite this sentence here um such that
the the the $50 well the $75 if that's
what it is um only appears
once not three times Cofe okay
so um if you want my help doing that
Melissa or and and truly uh uh Mr
chairman if I might uh the reason that
we're asking for this language change is
because we were putting the cart before
the horse it's very clear yeah I don't
think we have any problem with the what
they're doing here right they want to
collect the money and then send the
certific certificate instead of here's
your certificate and it's no good if you
don't send the money right I mean that's
right exactly okay all right any other
yeah go ahead um thank you and um Mr
commissioner do you know what
neighboring states charge for elevator
inspections I don't okay I don't
excellent question but I don't I don't
have that with me yeah representative
leean thank you Mr chairman good morning
morning so do you know how much it costs
you to inspect obviously $50 doesn't
cover it maybe 75 wouldn't either have
you ever figured out what it cost to
inspect an elevator because I think you
may have told us you have to bring
weights in and all that so it's pretty
labor intensive right and there are
we're talking about different kinds of
activities this fee is is strictly for
the certificate saying the state of New
Hampshire is aware that this unit has
been uh inspected and is safe to operate
that's really all that we're talking
about is the certificate and the cost
for that so follow up so yes go you
don't have a a fee for the inspection
itself just a certificate we do do y oh
it's $100 per hour oh okay well that
answers that then so maybe it's not that
unreasonable maybe that's why we have a
$300,000 plus yeah okay thank you sure
representative
McGuire yes thank you I would have to
say that a 50 or $10000 fee for somebody
that owns a commercial elevator which is
the only type that gets gets inspected
is is a rounding error it's it's not
going to make a diff they're not going
to shut down their elevators if you
double the fee so yes okay anybody else
want to represent if the inspection fee
is $100 do you think the inspection fee
is
adequate hard to say haven't analyed
that but again uh these these fees are
written in statute
um uh and and
the the revenue Generation by the
division far exceeds the expenses in
total
okay all
right 75 okay so we'll we'll rewrite
this and have an amendment for 75 okay
um and we'll vote on it at that time
let's go on now the next one I think we
accept it
already um unless specific Section 1 38
we already accepted yes uh so let's talk
about what's in
139 yeah I if you remember this was a
discussion
about um the list of uh infractions that
receive a warning as opposed to going
directly to civil penalty and the the
reason that we asked for this change in
house bill to is because although
157 grants the commissioner overall
civil civil penalty Authority there are
other chapters that we enforce that that
have different Provisions for civil
penalties and so we were just trying to
square that up um the the youth
employment law and the workers
compensation law allow us to penalize
without warning and so we we were adding
to that list in 273
to make it square with these other
chapters so this is a list of things
that don't need a warning right yes
correct yeah and and when these things
happen normally you wouldn't give a
warning is that it um or
sometimes sometimes okay there's there's
discretion okay all right any questions
on this section are we okay with it yeah
okay so representive camell's moves to
accept
Section 13 I'll second it 139 I believe
it yes seconded by representative Evil
all those in
favor okay thank you we we do
hands okay um so that was unanimous all
right so 139 is okay now second
injury
yes do do you want me to address the
house bill two question first or should
give us the whole background of the
situation and then I'm going to call on
the world's greatest workers
compensation expert good idea talk about
the second injury F so
um good morning thank you um so maybe a
good place to start is just to give a
little bit of background about what is
it um and how does it operate so the
second really it's called the special
fund for second injury so I'm going to
call it its short name the second injury
fund um it is a mechanism that is built
into the workers compensation law uh
that makes certain types of
reimbursement Provisions back to
insurance carriers who have paid monies
on com um acceptable compensable claims
so by Statute um and and really
historically going even further back you
know second injury fund programs started
popping up I I think in the United
States pretty popularly around the
around World War II and they were
intended to be in the stated purpose of
them uh is to be an incentive to
employers to hire and retain individuals
who have pre-existing conditions um so
through the second injury fund which is
funded Itself by insurance carriers so
if you look at the workers compensation
statute there's an assessment mechanism
I think we um reviewed this uh last time
that we were here with this committee
there's an assessment mechanism whereby
the
total amount of costs paid and benefits
by all insurance carriers whether
they're voluntary Market insurance
carriers or your self-insured pulled
risk style insurance carriers um from
the preceding year is taken and then the
um there's a
115% sort of markup or or modifier to
that amount um that that is then
assessed back to the insurance carriers
who pay either Prat a share of the um of
those total expenses to pay into the
fund so that's how the fund gets funded
insurance carriers can then submit
applications we call them eligibility
applications if an insurance carrier
believes that they have an eligible
claim for which they may be entitled or
able to get reimbursement um first and
foremost as a threshold they have to put
the fund on notice so injury occurs the
insurance care carer has this claim they
have 100 weeks to notify the fund 100
weeks from the date of the injury to
notify the fund I have a potential claim
here for which the fund May potentially
be liable if that requirement is met and
the insurance carrier then you know
believes yep I have um all of the
eligibility criteria I can meet the
eligibility criteria by providing
certain types of documentation and
Records they may file the application
with the supporting documentation to the
Department and a special injury fund
coordinator reviews it verifies if the
statutory eligibility criteria has been
met and if so they are entitled to
submit for reimbursement going forward
um for CLA specified claim expenditures
so not everything that an insurance
carrier pays on a worker's compensation
claim is eligible for reimbursement if
an insurance carrier can establish that
they do have an eligible claim um they
can get certain types of workers compens
ation expenses paid on that claim
reimbursed and primarily that really
falls under cash benefits Indemnity
benefits and medical benefits certain
types of expenses such as Vocational
Rehabilitation benefits and permanent
impairment award benefits are not
reimbursable by Statute uh so every year
by September 1st the insurance carrier
can file a application for reimbursement
outlining in detailing what they paid on
the claim that's vetted um they have to
meet a $10,000 deductible before they're
even eligible to get reimbursement so
they have to prove that they've met that
um and and then if they will be then
they if if they have submitted all of
that paperwork in a timely manner um
they can be reimbursed anywhere between
50% to 100% of the eligible expenses so
it's a mechanism whereby certain types
of reimbursements um can go back to
insurance carriers for claim expenses in
general I mean the fund has you know in
the past 5 to 10 years and I'll let the
commissioner correct my numbers if I'm
not remember bring them correctly has
had anywhere between 16 million to 20
million in it it depends on 22 is the
highest um kind of depends on the number
of claims that have been submitted in
the previous year uh and how much was
paid out in the previous year is that
the throughput uh a million a month or
something is that kind of well it's an
it's an annual process I'm sorry yeah
it's it's an annual process so
eligibility has to be determined at some
point after September member
1st eligibility can be determined at any
point um it's the balance that's in the
fund from the preceding year that's left
over then we assess based off the total
amount in claim expenses so each year
they submit how much they paid in claims
then it's modified and that set the
amount work so the injured worker has
already been comp got compensated and
got their claims set settled and all
this this is strictly about whether One
Insurance Company gets money back from
this fund or not correct and then and
then the industry as a whole is paying
the entire cost right of of the program
right so
so yes one car one carrier is winning
and one carrier is losing right on this
case but on the other case it could be
somebody else right yeah I understand
exactly now is this something common in
all states or is this something we only
have excellent question I was just
goingon to go there so so 22 states have
sunsetted similar programs um uh three
states have never had a program like
this so so half the country uh does not
have an active program I have in some of
the research that that I have done on
this uh some states sunsetted the
program decades ago and it is still
operating because there are these
accepted claims that continue and
continue because they they just they
have costs every year and so some states
are still operating but it's AO now it's
a closed system represent Ms thank you
Mr chair and thank you for coming in
course I'm sorry I wasn't here for your
original presentation
um in those states that have sunset this
um
mechanism any sense as to what the
impact on rates has been I mean my my
first reaction is that
it would increase rates because there
would be no reimbursement
for but all I would say about that is
that in in the design that we have in
New Hampshire all of the costs of the
program are then assessed on the in the
insurance carriers so it's to my mind
other than the 15% markup that we charge
uh it's Revenue neutral to the
industry the money goes back to the
industry and then we assess the industry
for the cost of the program but it's
expense positive right I mean you're you
and the industry both have to fill out
forms and check things and do all this
kind of stuff that's I think that's a
fair argument all right representative
McGuire commissioner would would it be
fair to say that what this is is an
insurance policy so that if some company
has a very large claim that is paid out
over decades the rest of the insurance
company contributes towards it I didn't
I didn't hear the last the contributes
toward paying this extremely large
claim yes uh I think the eligibility
however is not the the size of the claim
it's it's um do you have documentation
of a prior injury did the person have a
subsequent injury are they otherwise
eligible as opposed to oh we have we
have a million dollar claim so you know
give us that money
back okay representative
lean thanks Mr chairman so if I recall
two years ago you came in with similar
language and it was met with some
opposition I think uh the former Senate
President Peter bragon was concerned
about it Bob Scully from the New
Hampshire mode of Transport so is this
different than what you presented two
years ago or similar we did not we did
not propose a sunset in this version of
House Bill 2 because of the opposition
of the house the house did not seem to
have an appetite for doing that so we
did not propose it again uh uh what we
have proposed here is had really is uh
akin to what uh the chairman was saying
about administrative effort the there
was a recent Supreme Court case that is
um requiring the Attorney General's
office to defend the fund
in CA in cases where we have denied a
claim we have to defend the fund now at
two levels of hearing at the labor
department plus the Supreme Court plus
the Supreme Court if we get there um and
so we were trying and the court even
said in their decision there may be a
legislative remedy to this here here
here we are little hint here so what we
have proposed in this version of House
Bill 2 just addresses that that um
doubling of of hearing activity
regarding the SI we did not we did not
bring forward another sunset provision
okay so just to follow two years ago it
was the sunsetting of this that got
everyone's attention not what you're
proposing here I I think that's true
okay thanks and the poliy we we see you
know any act any decision to Sunset the
second injury fund we see as a policy
decision and for you all
okay so um what's the argument in favor
of having this is it that um workers who
have experienced previous injuries are
more likely to get hired than they might
otherwise is that kind of it I think
that that is a good characterization of
the original purpose however I would
also say that we now live in a world
that has an Americans with Disabilities
Act um and so a hiring honestly a hiring
decision really should not be made on
this basis in my in my opinion gotta
okay um any other thoughts here yeah I'm
I'm inclined
to get rid of busy work you know what I
mean that you know make work kind of
stuff and this sounds like a case where
if we got rid of the whole thing
insurance rates would actually be lower
right because there'd be less work
involved in getting them there right
yeah I think the the industry is better
able to answer that um I think the the
national Clearing House on on
compensation data uh probably will have
an opinion about that but on its face
you know we're charging the industry for
the total cost of the program plus
15% um I
see well but do you charge them
less what do you mean by the total the
the amount of claims that are paid we
determined the amount of claims that are
that are compensable under the program
MH and then we build the industry for it
right and you add 15% for yourself and
we had and we had 15% right okay how
many employees are in the department to
handle this there there is one full-time
labor grade 25 that works on this
program exclusively
um that we commit time and the director
of the division commits time
um sure sure I mean in total there as
the commissioner explained there's one
primary staff person whose sole
responsibility is to essentially
administer to the program there are
several letter levels of vetting on the
reimbursement applications that occur to
assure that the mathematical
calculations are correct and without
error um so in total staff persons who
work on the program with the caveat that
not all of them are fully dedicated to
that program it's it's four or five it
includes the director of worker workers
compensation division's time because um
he signs off on that individual signs
off on all reimbursement approvals as
the as the final um person saying that
it's it's satisfactory uh to to be
reimbursed so total five to six people
with one full time dedicated okay so it
sounds like if we're talking
um1
million times 15% you're
collecting um whatever um one and A5
million or or more is that kind of right
uh and only 16 current current value of
the program is about 16 million it's
been as high as 22 million um uh
so yes however the balance it doesn't
you know we don't put it in our pocket
or anything yeah but but no I'm I'm
going to what you're not spending comes
back to the general fund no different
fund oh okay different fund this this
fund is it's a true revolving fund and
the balance that's remaining as of March
1st I believe the balance remaining as
of March 1st rolls forward to depress
the the commitment so so it always
remains even the 15% always remains in
the fund I see so you charge some
expenses against the fund no no no no
expenses are charged to this fund at all
other than the claims
paid okay I see all right um yeah so I'd
be yes represent I was just I was trying
to understand what the um the um people
who were opposing getting rid of the
fund what their opposition
was I'll let them characterize okay well
I maybe someone I just don't understand
the opposition because it seems worth
sunting well I just remember at certain
points people telling me um well the
state's making money on this right
because we're we have people who are
insured and some we put in claims and
and but when I talked to das they said
well you know some years we make money
and some years we don't right you know
because some years their claims are high
and sometimes they're not you know so
and Mr chairman I can comment on that as
well uh our staff person has been
looking at the state's participation in
this and it is a mixed bag um uh two
years ago we we the state as an employer
lost
$200,000 and the most recent two years
we have gained uh nearly 200 and then a
bit more than 200,000 but it's a mixed
bag it depends on the claims it depends
on depends on how many claims the state
is paying because that'll determine our
assessment you know how how much will
the labor department charge the state
for participating right and and when you
make a claim is there documentation of
various kinds oh yes sure so there's a
lot of work here it sounds like okay um
but maybe this is not
so what do think let's assume well I
don't know how many think that
um we should sunset this this
fund um so that's what I think but I'm
feeling of sunsetting okay but but maybe
this should be a bill right is that the
the thought then it'll go to the labor
committee and all the sort of stuff
right because it's not affecting our
budget right so maybe we should pass
this part to help him out with the legal
aspects of it but make it a bill for
next time right does that make
sense huh yeah you like that idea okay
all right so where are we
here um so this is sections 140 140 and
I believe 141 14 address hearings
they're both the same any specific
questions on these two
sections no I don't see any all right
representative Camal yes I like to make
a motion to accept sections 140 and 141
I'll second it okay motion by
representative Cal and seconded by
representative eil to accept sections
140 and 141 all those in
favor all right unanimous very
good what else do we have anything any
other
labor no we we could talk all day if you
want but sure you have other
things so how much how much more in
fines are you going to give us so we can
balance our budget well that's that's a
double edged sword isn't it um um
because the fines come from somebody
right yeah yeah we're we're going just
like the elevator right we're raising
fees and all this sort of stuff
understand so yeah um and and I guess we
decided to not change your your um
discretion on those kind of things right
but we did talk about you tend to yes
you were charging somebody $12.50 or
something I don't remember what the
number it's the the largest revenue in
the restricted fund is is for fines that
we Levy against uh insurance carriers
for late reporting of coverage events
and um yes the the statute allows us to
charge up to $50 a day and we we are
currently our our rubric says $112 a day
okay so yeah so we would appreciate it
if you consider $20 a day or what you
know some some other number carriers
might not I understand all
right yeah they might get to be more on
time so okay any other things for the
commissioner no we're happy thank you
very much okay thank
you to vote on
137 we're going to wait till we get the
the handout right or do you want to vote
on it now no we have to amend it and
raise it
to Mr chair the language right so I
actually looked up the fees Maine is at
$50 and Vermont has an array if it's an
electric traction elevator and escalator
it's
250 um residential elevators and
stairway chair lifts are 100
so I think 75 is very reasonable
okay um I guess since we're here why
don't we vote on it right okay who's
making a
motion representative
C3 okay any second second second from
representative Griffin all right so
we're voting on raising the elevator fee
to $75 on section one and accepting
section
137 all those in
favor okay good unanimous with
representative Sweeney absent okay
good
now do we have somebody new who came to
talk about
something we have um J Bucky from
judicial Council here say that again Jay
Bucky from judicial council is here oh
the judicial Council yes welcome
and section 125 to
yeah so this is on page
56 right
do we make
a
hi good
morning right so we are on let's see
here 125 I think right
section
125 line
um so what is it um that's being asked
for here what's what's the change I
guess it's repealed and
reenacted I'm sorry representative I
mine doesn't have a line number my my
sheet I'm looking at so um adequate
representation for Indigent defendants
in criminal cas cases um RSA 604a col 6
is repealed and reenacted as follows yes
thank you apologies the intent behind
this uh Bill uh is to essentially rework
and streamline the payment uh for
services other than Council in indent
defense cases um the current system was
put in place uh when there are many
fewer uh services that were required and
you know over time thank you so
much the the frequency and the nature of
these Services is really grown
exponentially for example um I think
when when this uh original statutory
framework was adopted these Services
would only be requested in a small
minority of cases where a signed Council
was appointed and something like an
expert like a a ballistics expert was
requested and so it would require a
judge to look at the request and you
know these would be rare and the judge
would look review it sign off on it send
it back to us and this is all done using
the mail these days um there's a lot
more assigned Council using these uh
types of requests and also the Nature
has changed quite substantially so now
we have uh translation bills coming
through and those aren't really uh
controversial or large but they're
voluminous and they still have to go
through this process where they get
mailed around to different courts and
that takes up court time judge time and
it goes through several different steps
we've been working on other workarounds
to um streamline this using
administrative orders but a statutory
change is envisioned to really cut down
on the number of people have to look at
these and just to speed up reliability
and um efficiency I I brought a prop if
you'd like to see it just to show the
current number of steps it takes to have
a bill approved in our state two two
props
um we had a lean group just to look at
the original way that we approved this
is just translation bills the number of
steps
involved the number of people it took to
get one bill approved I see was
remarkable and so each box is a person
doing something yes okay either a step
or a person and it goes across lawyers
the courts and my office and um a lot of
these are done through the mail which is
another uh issue so the goal is there to
to Really reduce the number of cases
where a judge has to look at a bill you
know keep that for the high dollar um
discretionary types of things and
everything else would go through my
office for review but not um the level
of review that gets
brought and so you decided high dollar
is $1,500 is yes okay um all
right and are all of these three parts
of the same thing or they
different the other two are similar so
the other provision has to do with
Council fees and that's the same idea
essentially basically right now um
unless there's an administrative order
and there are some administrative orders
that have been issued to deal with this
but this would essentially make it so
that in any case where a lawyer does
work on an Indigent defense case and
they come in under the presumptive fee
cap which is set by the Supreme Court
then that bill would be forwarded to us
instead of for a judge to review because
as you can imagine judges and Court
staff spend a lot of time getting lawyer
bills which are not extraordinary
looking at them and then sending them to
us and that slows down the whole process
and also just makes it more difficult
for people to get paid in a reliable and
timely manner so that's what that the
um 604 A4 that's related to compensation
of council same idea streamlining that
process and having basically a threshold
over which bills would get judicial
review okay and 604 A6 the recommended
change there is to expand the areas
where the judicial Council can contract
with providers right now we can only
contract with certain limited types and
my hope there is that by being able to
contract with a wider array of providers
we could try to you use some of the
leverage that the state has and
negotiate more favorable rates in terms
of translation services um evaluations
all the sorts of things that come up
fairly regularly um but right now we
just pay you know the state pays them
all on a one-off basis instead of
Contracting in bulk gotcha so you could
either hire somebody or just have a a
rate that's agreed on ahead of time yeah
exactly okay very good other questions
from the committee representative Ms
thank thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for coming in again and I'm sorry if
I missed this in your uh in your
discussion but on page
57 um at the top uh Roman numeral three
where it says the executive director of
the Jud judicial Council May upon review
decline to process inv what is that
again is that basically saying
that that if an in that that you make
the determination whether it goes to the
administrative judge
or that's designed I didn't follow that
oh of course that's designed as a as a a
fail safe because we do review the bills
prior to payment so if we got in a bill
and it was flagged that hey this bill
doesn't look quite right or we think
it's duplicative of another bill that's
already been submitted we would then
tell the attorney this actually has to
go to a judge we're not going to we're
not going to review it at the judicial
Council we're going to send this to the
court for review um so it's designed to
allow that flexibility in a case where
we think a bill is either mistaken or
for some other reason um
problematic okay questions
representative I I don't really have a
question I have more of a comment it
seems to me with the challenges that the
judicial council is facing in general
any thing that we can do to help them
streamline the process should save money
and and time so I'd be in favor of um uh
approving these sections okay anybody
else want to representative cell I'll
second that motion okay all right
consider that emotion all right so
representative eel moves and
representative cell seconds that we
accept sections 125 through 127 of House
Bill 2 any further discussion all right
all those in
favor all right unanimous
excellent I wanted to ask you one
question while you're here um one thing
we've been talking about is um the
distinction between a misdemeanor and a
felony and um so we understand when it's
when it's something stolen or whatever
it's
$1,000 and maybe that ,000 was set a
very long time
ago um so would it how would it affect
if we change that to $2,000 or some
other number how would that affect your
your judicial
Council the fewer to answer broadly and
then to go more
specific felony is more expensive both
in times of time and also money for us
to deal with um the average cost for a
felony um is several High Times Higher
Than for a misdemeanor when paid through
a signed Council and again there's
different ways that we handle cases
public Defender contract and assigned um
for the average felony it's as I
mentioned several times higher the fewer
felonies that go that that are assigned
that brings down cost so if a if a
felony is not charged a felony but
instead comes forward as a misdemeanor
that's much more it's much less costly
part of that is due to just the amount
of litigation that's involved in a
felony a felony has um many more Court
hearings also the stakes are higher and
often times the discovery is more
voluminous um but even if not just the
number of steps that there are in a
felony case just takes longer attorney
has to come to each one of those the
person has to come um so depending on
what the number you look at depending on
how that case is handled um the average
cost just to give some some rough
numbers the average cost for an assigned
felony is roughly
$1,500 the average cost for an assigned
felony is $6,500 so it's several times
higher um and part of that factor of
four yeah again that's average not Med
the me those numbers are are quite
different um because certain cases for
example cases that go to trial cost much
more than a case that resolves early on
but that can give a rough idea of um
those cases speaks specifically to um
thefts uh the data I had basically
indicated that class B thefts which
would Encompass the current $1,000 to
$1,500 Benchmark about 47 a month in the
state um
I will note though that class B thefts
can also be Class B thefts because of
value and because of other factors or
some other um thefts like third strike
thefts that would fall into that so
depending on I don't have the data that
would break it down on any given
Benchmark where that would be how many
you know how many thefts are charged
1,00 to 1500 versus 1500 to 2,000 I I
don't have that I could I could probably
get get it for you know a specific time
period but um overall a felon is more
expensive than a misdemeanor um and a
very serious felony is more expensive
than uh a regular felony I I I've just
talked about regular felony bills
certain bills such as um aggravated flon
sexual assault death resulting cases
murder um you know any the very very
serious crimes those cost more than a
regular felony sure um so you don't know
how many um I guess the fraction of your
work that's due to theft in particular
or cases where this would be turn on a a
money amount you see what I mean
certainly my estimate would be roughly
20 a month 20 a month out of a 100
months out of out of how many does the
judicial
Council cover on average in a month all
cases I would have to I'm sorry I have
to go and and look that up I apologize I
have data per year i' have to all right
per year yeah we I can divide by 12 sure
[Laughter]
and are
you just to clarify you're speaking
specifically of criminal cases yes yeah
yeah
thank you this is Suzanne kerson from
the public defender um had this data
more at hand I want to give a a caveat
the public defender
has a better way of tracking individual
cases than the judicial Council
currently because our system is in the
process of being overhauled and they
handle the bulk of the criminal defense
cases in the state so we handle cases on
top of this but to give an idea of the
number of cases it's 22,000 cases and
that incp is as I think we talked before
charges dockets and that can include
anything from Felony misdemeanor
probation violations parole hearings
sentencing hearings motions to impose um
all those sorts of things so 20 cases is
nothing right I mean 20 cases a month
that's 4 four 500 a year right I mean
I'm sorry 250 a year and uh compared to
22,000 right this is like a little more
than 1% it's it's not a I will say that
obviously a felony because of the way
because of the structure felony is is is
more if it was for review hearings right
right but um
now I would assume most of these things
are somebody steals a car is that kind
of it um and maybe there's hardly any
difference between a car worth a th000
and a car worth 2,000 right I mean it's
every car is going to be a $55,000 thing
or something like that is it most most
cars are are charged that way unless
it's a particularly unwanted car yeah
okay all right so again this is probably
a bill not a not a hb2 thing but
representative evil yeah so um
just I was digging into this article
that you're so sick of me um mentioning
and one of the things that I found
interesting in the in the article that
was reviewing the Indigent defense uh
crisis was that there was um an a
program a clinical type program at
Franklin Pierce that the judicial
Council had gotten funding for they
cleared 323 cases in nine months and
apparently it was a really good program
so I asked Mr Bucky um if he thought it
would be worthwhile pursuing this again
and you can so I will I will ask you the
question but before and then you can
talk about the monies but before we get
too far uh it's like under
$100,000 and they cleared massive
numbers I mean I anyway go ahead Mr
Bucky thank you um yes there is a
program that was funded by federal funds
in the last bium which was quite
successful in recruiting um new lawyers
to take Indigent defense cases um the
judicial Council uh I in my role I would
strongly support refunding that program
for a couple different reasons one one
of the effects of that program was to
there's two two main effects first it
took attorneys who were
either coming to a new practice area so
experienced attorneys who were starting
to take criminal cases or attorneys out
of law school who were looking to really
become proficient in specific New
Hampshire criminal case work and it
achieved both of those goals and from a
uh societal Viewpoint that was great
because it brought in new attorneys
taking these cases from a very um
numbers and sense point of view from
from my role we were able to use that
program and leverage it to uh convince
people to say if you did this program
you had to commit to taking a certain
number of indent defense cases um and
that was very helpful for us because it
gave us several new lawyers they all
committed to taking these cases and they
and they took the cases and that was
great and now several of those attorneys
still take cases because they have a a
network of people who they you know
through the program they had mentorship
just in I can tell you that uh in
recruiting attorneys generally one of
the major barriers to have an attorney
take these cases is who am I going to
talk to if I have a question is there
some Network um because if someone wants
to you know if I'm a real estate
attorney and I would like to take an
ninine in defense case I'm not going to
do that unless I feel like I can do a
good job you know people we don't want
them to take those cases unless they
feel comfortable doing that so this this
sort of a model where we can offer
training as an inducement to take cases
um is powerful because a you know gives
training but B it's sort of a cost-
effective way of having folks take cases
who wouldn't ordinarily do them
gotta yeah just to follow up I mean we
talked about it um a little bit and
maybe we could get a firmer number from
Mr Bucky but apparently there's already
a counting unit in here in hb1 that we
could add some funds to but they would
be um no I know you're raising your
eyebrows but you know when you look at
the overall scheme of things um uh it's
and I actually I also talked to Melissa
about it it's a minimal amount of money
I think to clear 323 or 400 cases in a
year and it would help the judicial
Council a lot where it's already deeply
underfunded so it seemed to me like a
very lowcost
alternative so are you saying shifting
that money from a different judicial
Council account no I didn't say that I
thought it was I thought it was um if if
this is a better way to get cases
through than the other way right well
and we can we can talk about that but
um let let's I just really wanted to
raise the option as a way of moving
cases through in a much less expensive
way okay thank you representative run
thank you Mr chair um while you're here
I'd like to ask you your thoughts on the
young adult Court um there's been a
pilot that's been running in Manchester
where um uh people that are between the
ages of 18 and 25 I think that have been
charged I believe with their first
offense they um they go through a
special Court there's some case
management but there's I don't know if
there's evidence but um there's
indications that it would actually save
in the long run because it reduces
recidivism of this population and it
also enables them to get into um a
lifestyle or career choices where they
can be independent and contribute to
society taxes services whatever um
what's your experience been if any with
that pilot in Manchester I haven't been
involved with that pilot specifically
that young adult Court I will say that
generally um one of the things the
public defender does as part of their
mission is they staff um treatment
courts throughout the state and one area
my experience as an attorney was I was
involved in helping to create the the
drug court in Chester County I was part
of the committee that got it going more
than 10 years ago um I didn't establish
it myself personally but I had the
experience getting that Court going and
I I do think that as a
long-term someone's willing to take a
long-term view those courts are
absolutely worth it I think if you have
experience
seeing the results uh especially on
someone who you know goes from not being
a productive member of society maybe
incarcerated um especially if that
person has a family taking that person
and putting resources up front to help
that person really turn things around
huge difference and that has obviously
ripples across the family across the
community um but it is it it's a time um
it's a long-term view one area that I
would uh I'm eager to speak with about
anybody but in the judicial Council
especially right now we're in a
situation where because um you the
public defender it's budget is set every
two years the money that it gets upfront
is important because it helps it to
recruit and plan for the future
currently we're in a situation where the
public defender is the only defense
organization that really staff strug
courts across the state you know because
they're in every County um if that
doesn't happen um I don't think there's
a way for us to really staff those
courts through other contract or
assigned means or if we did it would be
at a much higher rate um and one thing
that I'm encountering currently uh is
that because of limits on the public
defender capacity we're having to use
more contract and assigned Council so
just to get to this idea that the money
upfront for organizations like treatment
judicial account excuse me public
defender really goes a long way um in
reducing the long-term costs because the
less money that goes towards a public
defender the more money comes up
ultimately for assign counsel contract
counsel because those bills have to be
paid constitutionally and I have to pay
them one way or another so just to to
link that issue uh to the ongoing issue
the public defender the public defender
I think supports it I support the
treatment courts they're important I've
seen their effect um but they do cost
money and that's money that needs to be
paid generally upfront because they have
to be paid up
front right any other questions
representative evil so um Melissa I'm if
we decided that we wanted to pursue this
um my understanding is it would just
need an amendment to hb1 and not just in
terms of adding more funding to it and
yes we correct that's correct we could
do two things we would get the um class
line from Mr bakia where the 100,000
would be added and we also can put in a
footnote if you'd like to say the
directive of what the 100,000 should be
going towards
um he told me it was what did you say
looking at
1091 the accounting unit 1091 and the
class I believe is 27 for
training well all right I'm Mr chair I I
I would like to pursue an amendment for
this and then we could talk about it now
or talk about it later uh later please
but yes okay I'll prepare one good all
right other questions for judicial
councel no all right well thank you so
much for coming thank you all right so I
think that's the end of this page right
page
three yeah yes
represent oh we have still have
something
open oh represent run oh I just wanted
to mention that I heard back from the
executive director of New Hampshire
Lakes regarding that decal program oh
yes and she had a conversation I think
this morning with uh Mr deer at Dees and
and she's now supports the repeal of
that because even though it um it is
making a little bit of money it's not
accounting for the administration
administrative burden that the
department has um in just the auxiliary
support of that so when we if you do
want to get to that yeah we we let's do
that in in a moment okay so what was 155
we're holding on oh that was Revenue
sharing Revenue sharing oh
good so I'm finally in the majority so I
can make a my own motion here all right
so um regarding section 155 on page
so I again I think this is It's been
suspended for a minimum of um uh 15
years or something like that and it's um
18 years is that what we decided 2007 or
2009 2009 2009 okay so so it's 16 years
and
um it's it's really full of all this uh
Antiquated stuff like the fur bearing
animals and all that kind of thing so so
I I'd like to move that we replace
section 155 with a straightup repeal of
RSA 31- a I'll second that motion okay
any other
discussion representative um just as I
said before when we were talking about
this I I I realize that the statute as
it is now is um not constructed
beautifully it could be revised I
personally under the the situation that
we're in with property taxes already I
would have a very hard time telling my
constituents that I supported the repeal
of this Revenue sharing provision
because um I just don't think it's
appropriate so I'll be opposing the
motion okay anybody else represent R I
will also be opposing it I I agree with
representative eel that we could
probably go into that and make some
improvements as far far as the revenue
sourcing to be sh to be shared but I
know my constituents in miramac are um
really stretched with property taxes and
I I have the personal belief that the
state should be sharing more of our
Revenue with our with granite Staters
and relieving the burden that they have
we have we have elderly people that have
to sell their homes one woman had to
sell her car just to pay her property
taxes and um I I I just don't believe
the repeal is in
order okay representative
Maguire yes than thank you I agree that
it will be taken badly by a lot of
people who think that this statute is
actually in
effect but the people that know that it
has been suspended every budget for the
last nine or 10 of
them AR it doesn't matter we could
replace it by instead of repealing it
just by saying that we we intend to
share Revenue with the towns and
municipalities you know see other
sections or whatever because that
particular statute is totally Obsolete
and and having been suspended it it just
makes the the uninformed will look at it
and say oh we're going to get 30% of the
meals and rooms revenue or whatever yeah
and and then get bitterly disappointed
when it doesn't happened yeah and every
budget since I've been in the house has
repealed that has suspended that section
so I'm in favor of of repealing it
rather than suspending it because resp
suspending it seems to imply that we
support the that section as opposed to
saying we support sharing Revenue with
the the municipalities
just to slightly clarify the the rooms
of meals sharing is in some other
section right it's not in the here right
we're we're not talking about that
representative M thank you Mr chair and
and and thank you for um letting
Representatives Eble and rung go before
me so I can say ditto ditto um I um I
also will be voting against this um and
uh I agree that it's um it's not worded
as elegantly as it could be um but I
think it just sends a a a a bad message
um particularly when we're all hearing
that people are very concerned about
property taxes yeah yeah I'll just make
the comment that I believe in the last
bium we raised the um amount of adequate
Ed Aid something like $200 million I
mean it was it was a very large increase
so anyways representative Griffin yeah I
I think it's time to clean this up we
haven't done it for 15 years our laws
are getting uh larger and larger and
larger the volumes and it's really time
that we we look at a lot of the sections
that are out of date and uh repeal them
they can be Rel
legislated when the time comes if it
comes yeah um I remember when
representative Maguire put in a bill to
uh get rid of the ban on explosive stove
[Laughter]
polish things like that anyways
representative
Le thanks Mr chairman I guess kind of a
piggyback on our newest member of the
division this is like a false narrative
that this is available and we haven't
used it since 2009 so we really aren't
taking anything away because there's
nothing to give and a lot of the laws
that tax laws that exist under the
statute have now been vacated so It
Seems like by suspending it people say
oh they've suspended Revenue sharing
well we really haven't we haven't used
this since 2009 so I'll be supporting
removing
155 all right thank you so any other
comments should we vote I just wanted to
say it is opposed by the New Hampshire
uh Municipal Association the repeal so
okay I just wanted to get it on the
record sure okay all those in favor
raise your hand okay we've got
six it looks like opposed three okay
thank you very much yes represent R the
vote we just took was that on 155 or an
amendment to repeal it it's an amendment
to repeal to change change the it'll
still be 155 but it'll instead of saying
it's suspended it'll just say it's
repealed okay so was okay right we're I
assume we're all set on that yeah yeah
okay go all right now now are we done
with this page are we yes okay
great okay let's go to get to the decals
here okay so this would be section 159
what is 158 are we still waiting on that
one um page 65 158 we were still waiting
from Dees on just an amount of the fees
they've collected for that I can't hear
you in 158 we're still waiting for a
response from Dees on the amount of fees
that have been collected on that we had
some outstanding questions on that item
all right so we'll still wait and then
um where's the decals it's 159 okay so
representative R I move that we accept
159 okay seconded by I'll second that
okay seconded by representative cambrell
so representative rung moves and
representative cambrell seconds that we
accept Section 159 of houseu two all
those in favor raise your hands okay
unanimous very
good
okay anything else here
oh since your wife here yeah what's that
oh barbering yeah no do we want to take
this how about this $10 million
on page uh
section8 by the way I had some sort of
good news this morning um which was that
I had been thinking the amount we had to
cut
um uh had all didn't includ didn't
include
the the um slot machine money right so
so I was thinking that we had to cut uh
to balance the budget like $770 million
right but it turns out if we accept the
slot machine money that's an extra
whatever off that that money you see
what I
mean so right so it's only 600 million
instead of but you know those things
count right so
every little bit counts yeah so so
anyway so to me that's good news maybe
not to everybody but anyways so all
right let's go on to this one so this
one is section 188 this is um a $10
million raid on the uh renewable energy
fund which
um uh again is is a big deal to balance
the
budget um and I believe it is sort of on
our Surplus statement yeah represent
McGuire yes um I would say that since
the house passed a
bill last week to rebate it to the
consumers I would say you want to make
sure your 10 million comes out before
they start doing
that I mean and you can do that by
checking your effective dates but
um if you want the 10 million make they
start dealing out pennies to every rate
payer in the state yeah so there's a
little bit of a Crossing issue because
that bill didn't come to us it's going
to Ways and Means and so I I guess I
maybe we should wait and I'll speak to
Ways and Means and see what what they
plan to do with it yes represent R um my
understanding from talking to someone on
um Science and Tech is that this section
may be illegal because that 10 million
is a that's in a dedicated fund the
renewable energy fund so if the money is
taken out it needs to go back to the
rate payers not the general fund because
it has a dedicated
purpose yeah so that might be a question
to be to be asked yeah I mean this is
law here
so um you
know well I think if
it I I'm just wondering if there if
there needs to be a distinction to
repeal the fund altogether but just
taking money out of it to be put in the
general fund may not be constitutional
since that fund was set up for a
specific that the monies are supposed to
be used for a specific purpose so unless
you dissolve the fund um but I I still
think that um you know that that's money
that was put there by rate payers and
they should get the money
back so I think what you're talking
about is um
maybe a moral issue or a you know what I
mean a policy issue but it's not really
a legal issue in the sense that the law
created this Fund in the first place
right and so we can change law and we
can modify you know make new law and and
um it wasn't the Constitution that said
there's a renewable energy fund right it
was law and so this is just new law
basically but my understanding is that
the law that set up this fund restricted
use of the funds for specific purpose so
if we're now taking those funds and
using them for another purpose like
funding the general fund that that we'd
have to change 362 DF colon 10 to say
that the funds that are in this fund can
be can be transferred out for other
purposes so I think not right so in
general subsequent law takes precedent
over earlier law right so but um so so I
I I really don't think so anyways
represent M thank you Mr chair I I just
want to take a step back and and and
really advocate for you know not
removing this money from the um from the
renewable energy fund I mean the the
renewable energy fund is one of the few
remaining uh tools that we have to try
to um get us off the um Reliance that we
currently have on on natural gas um
which is quite frankly D what is driving
up the cost of energy not only in New
Hampshire but also in all of New England
um if we really want to help rate payers
in the long term what we need to do is
diversify our supply of energy um and um
this fund was set up to do that it's
unfortunate that for at least this the
last several years we've had a
department of energy that has not been
um out there really encouraging
people to apply for the money that's in
this fund but um um if we take if we
remove this money um we are just going
to be setting ourselves back even
further from the goal which I think we
all have which is to reduce the cost of
energy to businesses and citizens across
the entire State this is a this is a a
in my opinion a Pennywise pound foolish
kind of exercise okay representative
McGuire thank you with all due respect
representative Ms that position was
argued on the floor last week and
defeated and right now the status of
that fund is that all the contents will
be rebated to the rate payers and I
agree with representative rang's concern
that maybe we shouldn't be rating the
fund for the general fund but the intent
is
that the renewable energy fund should
shall be used to directly reduce rates
in the near
term and that that was the house
position that we established all right
so all right representative leishman and
then we'll we'll move
on so I won't support as the chair said
raiding this fund but the chair is
absolutely right you hear people often
say you're breaking the laws but as a
chair is often known to say we write the
laws so I think the chair is correct we
can certainly take the money but I don't
agree with it okay thank you so um I
think we're going to be doing more with
possibly doing more with dedicated funds
it's one of those things on our list
right so maybe when we get a day to just
for all those things then we'll come
back to this one as well maybe that's
the best way to do it all right now that
we have representative Maguire here
maybe we should talk about barbering and
com cosmetology
um we're we're sort of waiting to hear
from oplc right yes but that's I can
tell you what the point is please do all
right there's two different uh sections
here one takes the
inspectors the mechanical inspectors and
the uh Electric electrical inspectors
gasfitters and so forth and take them
out of the oplc and move them to the
Fire Marshal's Office in the department
of safety because they work to some
extent they work for the Fire
Marshall and they are there for the
safety of all installations in the state
they're not really a licensing function
yeah that that we've moved to division
two oh and I believe they've accepted it
so okay so let's talk about barbering
barbering okay barberism or there's a
lot of
we'll we'll do a trim on that one
uh the this sounds like an Edna
joke which is worse than a bad joke for
the most part okay so regarding the
barbering it includes a definition of
shop which is useful because it's
referenced all throughout the statute
the other intent is to
change the inspection requirements which
are currently in statute as at least
once per year per
shop the oplc and most of the people
involved in the business think that's
excessive the intent is to make it so
that there is an inspection upon initial
license and after that every 2 years
or if there is an investigation or a
need to get
involved um we discuss that in Edna and
we all think that's
perfectly a perfectly reasonable change
the other change is that the governor
had with the help of oplc has found
a
federal um osip training on Sanitation
for Barbers and
cosmetologists so the intent is to tell
The Barbers and cosmetology the shop
owners that if you have a this
certificate and this training we won't
won't inspect you again unless there's
an issue which will save everybody a lot
of time and
trouble and Edna is fine with that the
trouble is that the language that's
given in House Bill 2 doesn't exactly
reflect that intention very well and
that's what the oplc is rewriting it in
order to uh properly address the issue
it um there's also a requirement that
schools have the same inspection
requirements as shops which is everybody
agreed that's only appropriate so
the it's a mild change to the inspection
requirements but um it makes sense it'll
save every everybody time in trouble but
you need to have the right language so
that it goes into the right pieces of
Statute okay so we can't approve it as
is no now the um excuse me
repres represent I agree with you 100%
representative Maguire um and then the
other thing that's in this section is um
the number of hours required for for
licensing I believe it's a minimum of,
1500 hours of training there is Senate
Bill 194 to reduce that to 1,200 hours
do you happen to know the status of that
because would we have to make that it
has not yet gotten to the house so it's
not the house position oh okay uh I
could certainly this will be um when
it's Rewritten it'll be a clarification
of of the intent when we get that Senate
bill I'll make it which will almost
certainly be coming to Edna I'll make
sure goes into effect after house bill
to so that it overrides the number of
hours okay good thank
you um other comments so it sounds like
we're not quite ready at this
point okay good so should we go back to
page one see if there's anything we can
get rid of
here uh Bale I guess we're still waiting
on that
one
[Music]
um what about the endangered species
stuff
that's
all
um
is I'm sorry I if this is the if those
are all the per oh this is the ones
we're waiting for the public hearing
yeah I feel like we should wait for the
public hearing there's lots of interest
in that on all of these things right and
then the the um site evaluation
committee section I think we also really
owe it to folks to wait okay all right
so that's all that
stuff
um okay so I made a deal with the group
two guys that on Friday we would spend
an hour with them and they can make
their
pitch uh for this section I'm you know
as I said yesterday I'm I'm very uh
reluctant and and especially on parts of
it but they're going to come sometime
on
Friday um so can we schedule them maybe
1:15 would that work yep that's what we
have told J it to schedule it at 1:15
we'll do bills in we'll do our new bills
in the morning and then we'll do the
group two at 1:5 for an hour at 2:15 and
then at 2:15 we'll pick up the rest of
the bills if we haven't gone through
them or we'll do some more AG or bud bud
work yeah okay Mr chair yes repres is
part of that discussion on the
retirement system can we is there any
chance and I I don't know if the timing
works but is there any chance we can get
an accurate estimate of the cost impact
of what's in hb2 from the New Hampshire
retirement system because they they've
IND they indicated in their testimony
that it's less than what the governor
has
proposed again assuming it's a 10e spend
right
so yeah rep
Melissa we have reached out to them on
that um I'm not entirely sure if we
would get it by Friday I don't know if
they have to send it back to the actuary
because the ACT what the actuary does is
look at what was in the bill and does
the analysis based on that um but it's
an open item that we have with them
we'll do our best to get something
Friday okay we can invite retirement in
Friday as well if you would
like so so just um I don't know if
representative McGuire was a where but
when we talked to the retirement system
about this section um they said that it
would lower the unfunded liability so
yes because they told us the same thing
because the governor rounded up when she
put in her funding requirements okay so
um do you have a sense
of if the UN if you want the unfunded
liability to go down by a million do how
much you have to uh spend per year in
general you have if you want to put a
million dollars in today that'll lower
the unfunded liability by a
million right so if she's doing it over
10 years right so if you want to lower
it by a million
that's 100,000 or a little
more okay every year every year right
and so we heard that the unfunded
liability was going down by 98 million
okay
so um so divide by 10
roughly okay the actuaries will have
detailed numbers but generally that's
kind of how it works okay so that's a
that's a big deal right we're talking
about 10 million a year
difference off of the 56 million or
whatever this is right so yeah yeah
okay whatever the
um the unfunded liability CH is
recalculated every every year at least
every year based on the investment
returns and the um and how much goes
into it and all and also all legislative
changes and we have a whole bunch of
legislative changes that are going to be
debated this
week okay
all right
so that's it
right
okay
um now going forward type of
stuff um so generally speaking so
tomorrow we're going to have our our
public hearing um Friday we have bills
and that sort of stuff um we're rapidly
running out of time for the whole budget
the our deadline is uh two weeks from
tomorrow is the last time to act right
so we're talking
about um what four meetings next week
and and another two or three the
following week so so about
seven maybe six or seven more meetings
um but I think that's enough time to to
get into all this this kind of
thing
um
the so I don't
know maybe we should just call it a day
for
today um because people want to go vote
and deal with Town related
stuff
um yeah
okay is that good so why don't we uh
let's move representative leean you want
to say something okay why don't we move
into caucus mode I think and and we'll
talk about that yeah um I'm I'm still
working with Dees on Section 11 okay um
we haven't taken AC that's still on hold
I just you didn't address it so I wasn't
sure if you knew that we hadn't taken
action on that
yet it's yes it's on our sheet as not
having okay all right I I'll have more
information when we do get to it okay so
how about for Friday right okay and
Friday um are we meeting at
10: yes okay yeah and we do have new
bills and we'll probably have some bills
from Thursday right
so okay all right thank you so uh so
we'll go into caucus we won't meet this
afternoon okay all right
good and if you if you
look
e
e e